[Música]
a
escala en parís aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
hoy les hablamos de vino de como el
cambio climático está afectando a la
viña de por qué la producción esta
temporada en américa del sur está siendo
más baja y de la importancia del big
data para el futuro del sector y lo
hacemos con un gran conocedor pau roca
que es director de la organización
internacional del vino pau muchisimas
gracias por estar con nosotros gracias
estoy encantado de estar aquí
y poder contestar a las preguntas bueno
pau roca es español del penedès en
cataluña que es una región donde se
hacen excelentes cavas y está al frente
de la organización internacional del
vino que representa a 48 estados pero no
es tan china y eeuu los veremos pronto
en la organización en algún momento
tendrán que venir porque de momento pues
si somos muy representativos tenemos del
65% de la producción por decirlo de
alguna manera
esos dos países que ha mencionado pues
son muy importantes el primero la china
porque es el segundo país del mundo en
superficie de viñedo después de españa
con casi un millón de hectáreas de
superficie destinada a la vid y
eeuu el primer país consumidor del mundo
con lo cual son dos campeones a los que
esperamos con los brazos abiertos
diversas razones pues hacen que no hayan
estado en la organización aunque tiempo
atrás lo estaban hay dos provincias
productoras en china que si son
observadores y antay y ninja y nos
aportan pues también sus expertos y hay
otro país de américa latina que también
les gustaría no que integrar a esta
organización activamente pues somos
un poco
buscando la forma de que entre bolivia
bolivia es un país muy interesante
porque si hablamos de cambio climático
bolivia pues es un exponente del viñedo
de altura de
casi a 3000 metros pueden estar los
viñedos plantados y eso hace que sea muy
peculiar la producción de vino en ese
país de vino y de singani en dos
productos muy muy
además de buenas calidades y podría
convertirse bolivia en un modelo para el
futuro bueno al menos es un modelo de
estudio
bueno el precio del vino ha subido y ha
subido por varias razones que tiene que
ver la guerra en ucrania la guerra la
guerra de ucrania pues se añade a un
problema más que tenemos que
principalmente los precios suben no
tanto por el costo de la uva sino por el
transporte por la crisis de la cadena de
suministro que viene generada por el cob
y 19 por el distinto
distinto la distinta velocidad a la que
los países entran y salen de la crisis
de 2020 y eso genera pues una crisis de
transporte
crisis de todo tipo de suministros el
vino es muy importante en el comercio
internacional pero además todos los
insumos pues quedan
dijéramos en una situación difícil de
transporte también los palets también
los contenedores y es a
eso se le añade pues la crisis
energética y la inflación y eso es una
crisis encima de otra crisis no la
crisis de ucrania viene a añadirse a lo
que ya tenía ya prolongar el
encarecimiento y las sanciones a rusia
como influyen porque es importador no de
donde no mucho no mucho porque han sido
muy en el segmento más alto de precio
pero en definitiva si es una disrupción
en el comercio en américa latina lo
decía en la introducción se ha visto una
disminución de la producción tres países
que forman parte de la organización
brasil-argentina de chile registrar esta
temporada un retroceso es preocupante
porque a qué se debe ser retroceso no lo
es porque en realidad lo que estamos es
comparando un año con otro y
lo que pasó en la vendimia anterior es
que tuvimos una gran cosecha en esos
tres países
y este año vuelve un poco a la
normalidad
y si lo comparamos con una media de 5
años pues quieres darle en la media lo
que es interesante es que el cono sur y
todo el hemisferio sur pues representan
más o menos un 25 un 30 por ciento de
la producción mundial y eso
supone
un equilibrio para los desajustes que
pueden producirse cada vez más en el
hemisferio norte en definitiva todos
sufrimos del cambio climático pero la
diversificación de entre dos hemisferios
hace que los riesgos pues se puedan
compensarse porque en europa como está
el panorama o sea qué previsiones hay
porque ha habido inclemencias del tiempo
que hacen que tal vez haya menos
producción
este año ha sido difícil como lo fue la
anterior el anterior fue realmente
una reducción importante y ya veníamos
de otro
estamos ante dos fenómenos muy puntuales
de de todo tipo no desde
tiempo nomás que de clima de tiende el
mal tiempo que hace en algún momento y
algún fenómeno pues que hace que tanto
el granizo como los incendios como la
sequía pues esto naturalmente el
producto pues el viñedo sufre
y en el hemisferio norte pues se nota
muchísimo porque hay más tierra hay más
hay más continentes y por tanto aquí es
donde donde
nos encontramos ante este fenómeno
también ocurre en el hemisferio sur
hemos tenido incendios y momentos muy
difíciles en australia
y bueno esta es una realidad que nos
viene un poco impuesta por el cambio
climático
no es no es que esos fenómenos sean el
cambio climático
pero la suma de todo esto la integridad
de los fenómenos es lo que está
ocurriendo no grandes grandes
desajustes grandes tormentas grandes
todos cambios de temperatura muy bruscos
son elementos que tenemos que considerar
como la manifestación de un cambio
climático que nos lleva a un
calentamiento global a finales de
octubre méxico acoge el congreso mundial
del vino más concretamente en ensenada
baja california el estado vitícola por
excelencia en méxico el sector ha
crecido mucho allí quería preguntarle
justamente el cambio climático es el
mayor reto hay preocupación en el sector
si es
es lo más es lo que más en este momento
la mayor preocupación del mundo y de en
el sector del vino porque nunca hemos
sido negacionistas porque los
productores pues siempre han percibido
esta realidad y llevan años registrando
avances en
[Música]
en momentos de vendimia
cambios en el comportamiento de la
fisiología de la vid en fin son
elementos que conocemos estudiamos
seguimos
tenemos
que buscar soluciones justamente qué
medidas se están tomando se está
estudiando por ejemplo el cambio de
cepas
este puede ser
no es solamente el cambio de cepas las
cepas
tienen variedades
también hay clones que dentro de una
misma variedad no buscamos la
uniformidad creemos que en la diversidad
está la respuesta no en la biodiversidad
también de la propia viña no de esa esa
resiliencia que tiene la especie en
orbyt is vinífera es una especie que ha
ido acompañando al hombre durante ocho
mil años y esto hace que pues sea un
producto que un producto una una planta
que está muy que puede dar respuestas no
esto es una de las de las actuaciones
puede ser también la forma de conducción
de la viña no la forma porque la
fisiología de la viña pues y luego por
qué no decirlo también hay oportunidades
porque nadie pensaba que pudiéramos
tener vino espumoso que por cierto muy
bueno en el reino unido
en noruega o en suecia hay países que
muy fríos que ahora sí pueden
últimamente y luego pues en el sur de
alemania que siempre tenía dificultades
de llegar a unos niveles de madurez está
corriendo hacia el norte
sí tampoco nada es todo es muy relativo
en nada es una verdad absoluta porque
hay que ir viendo como esto ocurre pero
bueno es muy importante sobre todo ser
conscientes adaptarse adaptarse
hay una parte de mitigación importante
en el sector que es el cuidado de los
suelos estamos volviendo a mirar bien el
suelo como un organismo vivo eso es muy
muy importante como captor de co2
y bueno las prácticas de cultivo son
fundamentales conocer bien el viñedo y
vivimos en un mundo digitalizado donde
el big data es muy importante para
muchos sectores de qué manera puede
ayudar al sector del vino el big data
pues entre otras cosas puede ayudar a
hacer frente al cambio climático porque
estamos inundados en datos
tenemos muchos captores en la viña
tenemos estamos tenemos muchos muchos
datos pero no somos capaces de digerir
los no y eso hace que la inteligencia
artificial
es la que nos pueda acompañar a tomar
decisiones a interpretar lo que ocurre
más allá que la inteligencia humana
porque es un complemento y una
herramienta enorme
pues por ejemplo que estamos pensando en
desarrollar una serie d
pues de aplicaciones o de dye sports que
pudieran ser útiles para el sector para
anticipar algún momento pues difícil
algún momento pues anticipar las
situaciones que en este momento nos
encontramos
agua de fin de precipitaciones que
puedan ser problemáticas y todo esto
pues
anticipar también problemas de
infecciones
criptogámicas
cuestiones que la viña pues nosotros
sabemos cómo
digamos que podemos anticipar con la
inteligencia artificial y con la
cantidad de datos que tenemos algo que
va a ocurrir con algo de tiempo más
tiempo que antes pues muchísimas gracias
por roca ya no nos queda más tiempo
muchas gracias por haber venido hasta
nuestros estudios hoy qué rápido se ha
pasado se ha pasado muy rápido y muchas
gracias a todos ustedes por habernos
acompañado ya saben que también nos
pueden seguir por internet en rf y
mundo.com bien france24 puntocom hasta
pronto muchas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]